i'm currently here in
osaka japan i'm from nigeria from hong
kong
i'm an entrepreneur from israel i'm from
karachi pakistan
i'm from atlanta georgia i'm mostly from
texas i'm from
honolulu hawaii hey i'm taichi a
japanese diplomat and a tomb raider
i'm from chile i'm from portugal i'm
from dallas texas by the way of sudan
from the windy city chicago illinois los
angeles
i'm from augusta georgia and my family's
originally from antigua in the caribbean
and i'm currently about an hour outside
of yosemite national park
enroute to the gsb a fun fact about me
is that they used to be a real life
cowboy
one fun fact that i will throw out there
is i have an ep dropping out in about a
month so if you check that out shameless
plug
i was twice the israeli breakdance
champion
when i was 16. in fact i grew up right
next to disneyland and went to disney
elementary school
after college i joined a professional
bollywood dance company
i'm excited to master art of virtual
hugs
fun fact about me is that my first
career was as a music producer
one fun fact about me is i'm a level 8
arcane trickster in dungeons and dragons
my fun fact is that i speak four
different languages
i have an incredibly lazy french bulldog
named prince silva
a fun fact about myself is that i
unicycled once for
taco bell commercial aired on the nba
all-star basketball game i'm married
with a two-year-old son
and have another son who's come in two
weeks after school starts
one fun fact about me is that i really
enjoy mopane worms which are a
caterpillar that's eaten
in southern africa i'm currently serving
as an army helicopter pilot
and i think the thing that i'm looking
most forward to is joining this next
chapter of my life with a cohort of just
amazing people what i'm most excited
about is meeting all these amazing
students
uh that are going to be in the gsb
community there's such good energy and
incredible people as part of our class
so it's going to be very invigorating
and energizing to finally be on campus
alongside all of you i am so excited to
get to the gsb
and me to all of the incredible people
who i know
are my classmates uh i just think it's
really rewarding to hear
what my classmates are thinking and i
really enjoy that space for shared
perspective
i hope we can bring to bear all of the
creativity and optimism of this
community and really rise to the
occasion
stay true to your mission celebrate that
you have gotten through
and know that you are capable of getting
through
anything thank you for believing in
yourself and taking that risk
now go and pay that forward to the world
be proud stay humble so cheers to class
of 2022 and to all of you
who are strangers now but by the time
you see this video i'm sure we'll all be
[Music]
friends